موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله رحبت السعوديه هو الولايات
المتحده باتفاق القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريع على تمديد اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار لمده خمسه ايام اخرى وذكرت
الانباء السعوديه ان طرفها اتفق على
مناقشه وقف اطلاق نار طويل الامد وعلى
ضروره اخلاء المستشفيات من الجهاز المسلحه
قال دفع الله الحاج علي مبعوث الخاص لرئيس
مجلس السياده في السودان للجزيره قال ان
الجيش السوداني قادر على الحسم واضاف دفع
الله ان الجيش لن يتفاوض مباشره مع من
وصفهم بالمتمردين
اعلنا مكتب تنسيق المساعده الانسانيه
التابعه للامم المتحده للمواجهات هي
المسلحه في السودان اجبرت نحو مليون
واربعمائه الف شخص على النزوحي الى مناطق
داخل السودان وخارجه
تعرضت العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف لهجوم روسي
بالصواريخ وطائرات المسيره واقل السلطات
كيفن 11 صاروخا من نوعيه اسكندر اطلقت
باتجاه المدينه وانها
اسقطتها كلها واقلها وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيين الهجمات الروسيه على المدن
الاوكرانيه يجب ايقافها عبر تعزيز
الدفاعات الجويه بما في ذلك التزود
بالطائرات اف 16
وكان حاكم مقاطعه بالجراده الروسيه قال ان
حل مشكله القصف واستهداف المقاطعه المتكرر
يكمن في ضم مقاطعه
قالت شرطه
اشتباكاتنا دارت بين الشرطه ومواطنين من
القوميه الصربيه حاولوا السيطره على مبنى
بلديه البلاد
الى ذلك ادانت المتحدثه باسم حلف الناتو
بشده الهجمات التي وصفتها بغير المبرره ضد
اقوى حفظ السلام شمال كوسوفو والتي ادت
الى اصابه عدد من افرادها واضافت ان
الهجمات غير مقبوله على الاطلاق وطالبت
بوقف العنف فورا وحتى حكومه بلغراد
وباريستينا على استئناف الحوار
بدوره قال وزير الخارجيه
الروسيهم واعتبر ان تصاعد توتر الاوضاع
بين صربيا وكوسوفو ينذر بالخطر وحذر
لافروف بان ان انفجارا كبيرا ينضج وسط
اوروبا
اشكركم على متابعتي هذا الموجز القاكم
بحول الله على راس ساعه المقبله اينما
كنتم اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]